how do you stay driven I'm gonna ask you  a question how don't you stay driven  well let me get this right you won the  lotto of the universe which is you are a  human being on earth you I'm just gonna  say this I mean I don't think people  think about this you won the lotto you  in the universe you're not some weird  specimen in Mars that does nothing  you're not you know a bird you know you  know you're not a sunflower like you are  a human being on earth you won the  ultimate ultimate lottery and you're not  driven and you're not fired up and  you're not going for it and you're  willing to sit like a lump and just wait  till you die  you suck like I don't know you suck  like I how do I stay driven because I  couldn't even comprehend the alternative